il y a pas un bras en donneur il y en a
deux mais accompagné de parole à chaque
fois qui sont
[Applaudissements]
parlez exactement vous avez fait deux
bras d'honneur c'est ce que vous êtes en
train de dire à l'Assemblée
[Applaudissements]
avant de nous présenter ce texte madame
berger votre majorité aurait gagné je
crois à s'offrir une séance
d'introspection je vous rafraîchis la
mémoire 11 condamnations dans la
majorité dont celle de violence envers
une ex-compagne oui mise en examen dont
celle du secrétaire général de la
présidence de la République excusez du
peu et pardon monsieur le garde celle du
garde des sceaux usés l'un et l'autre de
prise légale d'intérêt pendant que notre
président de groupe là aussi descendait
de la tribune le Garde des Sceaux a fait
un bras d'honneur c'est quelque chose
d'assez à qualifiable
parce que si c'est le cas ça n'est
absolument pas admissible alors je vous
laisse
finir vous n'avez pas à faire les bras
d'honneur dans l'enceinte de l'Assemblée
nationale j'ai entendu les propos du
président Marleix
sur ma mise en examen
je veux rappeler que non seulement je
suis présumé innocent et constitutionnel
mais je suis innocent et je le dirai le
moment venu
effectivement madame la Présidente j'ai
réagi
avec beaucoup vivacité
je tiens à dire qu'il y avait
autour des gestes qui me sont reprochés
des paroles qui tendaient n'ont pas à
viser le président Marleix mais avisé le
mépris c'est comme ça que je l'ai conçu
qu'il avait pour le respect de ma
présomption d'innocence je n'ai porté
aucune accusation monsieur le ministre
j'ai rappelé un fait une mise en examen
et un renvoi devant une courrectionnelle
qui est la Cour de Justice de la
République ce sont de simples faits je
suis désolé si vous êtes renvoyé devant
la Cour de Justice de la République je
n'y suis pour rien cette impressionnant
vous êtes le premier garde des sceaux
dans cette situation là que ça vous
plaise ou non les excuses que je demande
ne sauvegardées ici
avec beaucoup de force que
je n'ai pas voulu viser le président
Marleix mais si mon geste a été mal
interprété je lui présente mes excuses
ainsi qu'à toute la présentation
nationale